- Yeah, that was pretty good, right?
It's like I'm high right
now, it's really hot,
I don't know how you do it, man.
Maybe, just, I have,
I don't, I'm not even.
Alright, here we go.
Too much hair product in my hair, mmkay.
Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Aleks, and
my one word is belong,
and I believe the world
would be a better place
if more people felt that they belong.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is be
a blessing to somebody.
Over to you, Maya Angelou.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- There's an African-American
song, 19th century
which is so great, it says,
♫ When it look like the sun
♫ Wasn't going to shine anymore
♫ God put a rainbow in the clouds
Imagine.
And I've had so many
rainbows in my clouds.
I had a lot of clouds.
But I have had so many rainbows.
And one of the things I do
when I step up on the stage,
when I step up to translate,
when I go to teach my classes,
when I go to direct a
movie, I bring everyone
who has ever been kind to me with me.
Black, white, Asian,
Spanish-speaking, Native-American,
gay, straight, everybody,
I say, come with me,
I'm going on the stage.
Come with me, I need you now.
Long dead, you see.
So I don't ever feel I have no help.
I've had rainbows in my clouds.
And the thing to do, it seems to me,
is to prepare yourself so that you can be
a rainbow in somebody else's cloud.
Somebody who may not look like you.
May not call God the
same name you call God
(laughing) if they call God at all.
You see.
And may not eat the same
dishes prepared the way you do.
May not dance your dances.
Or speak your language.
But be a blessing to somebody.
(whoosh)
- This message resonates
with me as a human being,
as an instructor, as a
speaker, as a leader.
It is super important that
you take responsibility,
not only for yourself, but
for the well-being of others.
Because ultimately you never know
what kind of impact you
could have on others.
When I was a student, seven years ago,
I struggled asking women to dance.
So here was I, sort of a beginner dancer,
going to socials, and
just being too afraid
to mess up, make mistakes, and people
not wanting to dance with me.
And I remember there was a short woman,
she was like 5' 1", 5
foot, she came up to me,
she was an advanced
dancer, she had no reason
really, to ask me to dance.
But she saw how afraid I was,
and she offered to dance with me.
And for multiple socials
as I kept going out,
she would always ask me to dance.
And every time I'd get nervous,
I'd make mistakes, I'd be hard on myself,
I'd start looking around, I'm looking
at all these other people dancing,
and that being intimidating for me,
she would tell me that it's okay.
That it's not important.
Just keep dancing, smiling,
that I'll get better.
I saw her about six
years later at a social,
by this point, I was
already an instructor.
When I saw her at one of our socials,
I ran up and I gave her a hug,
and I told her how much
of a difference and impact
she made on me, on my confidence,
and was one of the pivotal
reasons why I stuck around.
Even though at the beginning,
I was one of the worst dancers.
Never underestimate how powerful a simple
hello, a thank you, a you're
going a great job can be.
Every single day is an opportunity to make
a positive impact, in
the smallest of gestures
in people's lives.
And all it can sometimes take,
is just one second of you stopping,
and doing what you feel is right,
versus walking away and
not wanting to deal with
the hassle of things.
Take responsibility,
not only for yourself,
but take responsibility for others,
and be a rainbow in somebody's cloud.
(whooshes)
The question of the day is,
what's one regret that you have right now
where you wish you could've been a rainbow
in someone else's cloud,
but you didn't take action?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm excited to see what you have to say.
I want to give a quick
shoutout to Emma Hayward,
Emma thank you so much for
purchasing Evan's book,
it really means a lot to us.
I'm really curious when you
figure out your one word,
and when you do, leave
it in the comments below,
with your answer.
Thank you so much for watching,
we believe in you, and
we hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(typewriter clacking)
- I guess the advantage
that my generation has,
when we were in film school,
and we're starting in the film business,
the door was absolutely locked.
And it was a very, very high wall.
And nobody got in.
Therefore, all of us...
Beggars and scroungers
down at the front gate
decided that if we didn't
sort of band together,
we wouldn't survive.
And that if one could make it,
that one would help
all the others make it.
And we would continue to help each other.
So we banded together.
That's how cavemen figured it out.
Any society starts that way,
any society begins by realizing
that together, by helping each other,
you can survive better than
if you fight each other,
and compete with each other.
If I got a job, I would help
somebody else get a job.
If somebody got more successful than me,
it was partly my success.
My success wasn't based on how
I could push down everybody
that was around me.
My success was based on how
much I could push everybody up.
And eventually their
success was the same way,
and in the process they pushed me up,
and I pushed them up,
and we kept doing that.
And we still do that.
And even though we all have
in essence, competing companies,
we see it as, if everybody succeeds,
or my friend succeeds,
then everybody succeeds.
And that's the key to it, is
to have everybody succeed,
not to gloat over somebody else's failure.
One of the basic motifs of fairy tales
is that you find the poor, unfortunate
along the side of the road,
and when they beg for help,
if you give it to them,
you end up succeeding.
If you don't give it to them,
you end up being turned
into a frog or something.
It's something that's been
around for thousands of years,
a concept that's been around
for thousands of years.
It is even more necessary today,
when people are much more into their own
engrandizement, than they are in
helping other people, I mean
the one thing you hear
at the academy here,
is constantly about public
service, about helping others.
I don't think there's anybody who's
become successful that doesn't understand
how important it is to be part
of a larger community,
to help other people
in the larger community, to give back
to the community.
It's not something you do, you start doing
when you've made it.
Now I'm on the top, I can sort of,
enhance my joy and self-esteem
by helping the poor underlings.
it's when you are at
the very lowest level,
and you're struggling.
When we were in film school and stuff,
we were all very, very poor,
we were all very, very struggling,
we all need jobs very desperately,
and if one of us couldn't
get a particular job,
we'd send another friend
in on the interview.
Because we were hoping that
one of us would get the job.
So you do it right from
the very beginning.
You can start every single day
whether it's helping
your brother or sister,
or helping your peers at school,
or helping in the community,
but it's not just a kind
of public service thing,
it's a way of life.
If America is the pursuit of happiness,
the best way to pursue happiness
is to help other people.
'Cause there's nothing else
that'll make you happy.
You can be as rich and famous and powerful
as you want to be, and it
will not bring you happiness.
And that's said over
and over and over again,
it's such a cliche, it hardly goes,
it hardly needs to be said, but people
don't understand that it's actually true.
You can find people,
rich, powerful, and famous
and they aren't happy.
And you can find people
who have discovered
the fact that it's really helping people.
It's really being compassionate toward
other human beings that makes you happy.
- At the risk of sounding like
a Miss America contestant,
the most fulfilling
things I've experienced
have truly been the human interactions.
Spending time with women in village banks
in Mexico with Think, a
microfinance organization.
Meeting young women who were the first
and only in their communities to attend
secondary school in rural Kenya
with Free the Children,
a group that builds
sustainable schools in
developing countries.
Trucking with guerrilla
conservationists in Rwanda.
It's a cliche because it's true.
That helping others ends up
helping you more than anyone.
Getting out of your own concerns,
and caring about someone
else's life for awhile,
reminds you that you are not
the center of the universe.
And that in the ways we
are generous, or not,
we can change the course
of someone's life.
Even at work, the small feats of kindness
crew members, directors,
fellow actors have shown me
have had the most lasting impact.